I don't feel guilty about my coffee I
don't feel guilty like it's the same
thing I was saying the other day about
you know I could you know for the cup of
coffee a day all the things you could do
and I'm like I look forward to that
coffee so much I don't care that it's a
waste of me I don't care that I give
Starbucks four dollars and 87 cents at
least twice a day for a drink that cost
them less than seven cents and creates
garbage for the world I mean everything
about it is just disgusting and I really
loathe myself when I throw that empty
cup in the trash but when I get that cup
it's like I get a high four I get so
excited
that's what's but that's why you look at
what's worth it to you what did you
learn in your research for this book
that what's like a nugget that maybe I
can take into my life and our listeners
can take into theirs on just some money
advice that's simple and not
overwhelming well this is gonna be
slightly overwhelming okay that's not
what I paid you for yeah sorry oh my god
I only came on here because I'm being
financially blackmailed
so yeah well so what i did when i was
starting was and i know you just said
you don't look at anything so i'm really
sorry to stress you out but you I
printed out my bank statements for the
whole year printed them out and then
because they they do it by month and
then I went through them with a
highlighter and I highlighted stuff that
seemed insane to me
like so I would be like well that's very
high or I would be like wait a minute
why is my car payment so much or like
why is you know this kind of thing I
realized I had two subscriptions to
something and and I was like oh I don't
need two of those so write up one or one
thing I noticed was I was paying a lot
for parking in LA and I was like do I
really like I would run into a store for
15 minutes pay for four hours it's like
no don't do that so I like went through
and then I made a list of what not I'm
Jana and I hate this sort of like
generalized information that's like
don't buy a latte don't buy avocado
toast because that doesn't apply to
everyone so I was like you can have a
latte but go through your bank
statements and notice what what is too
much for you personally mmmm I'll buy
coffee every day and or makeup I mean
you know coffee is important to me but
like I'm good but I I was like parking
is not necessary in this situation or
like you know drive around for another
second and look for an open spot door or
like um you know oh well I like I looked
and was like oh my god my car insurance
is so high so then I left that car
insurance and looked for a better deal
like ratings where I wouldn't have ever
rode out yeah I know it was one month I
talked about in the book where I bought
$600 worth of stuff on Amazon what what
was that why yes I went through and was
like oh Jesus like I didn't need this I
didn't need this I didn't need this and
I was like okay that I was whatever I
was uncomfortable with I could see it in
front of me I know that's that's a good
point you're spending it certainly based
on your mood and your thoughts I the
other day I went shopping and I bought
like one shirt and that my mood was
instantly elevated like the person I was
with was like what just happened to you
and I was like I bought something mm-hmm
and I'm trying to you know do Marie
Kondo and get crap out of my life and
not have any more things but it truly is
like buying things makes you feel good
sometimes trying to get it out of my
system you said something about yeah the
coffee's I get I spend $16 on coffee a
day every day and is that for I don't
care were cups yeah it's like it's like
maybe two or three Starbucks at least to
everybody you're okay with that then
whatever brings me joy
you know what Gaby I often say to myself
what if I die tomorrow like what is
saving for I don't like I don't think
the world is going that great and I
don't trust that even my money is gonna
be in the banks when I want it so I'm
kind of like let me just spend it up
like there's a party there vacillates
between spend it all or save it all and
so I can pay for my you're me in season
one really yeah that's like what I came
into it with and my dad my parents
like can't take it with you man cuz
they're like baby boomers that's what
that's what my dad says yeah the next
day it'll be like well we are broke
Nikki and that's like a pic Elaine mom
and dad what are we
my mom says often oh well you're our
retirement plan yeah it is a nightmare
oh I say that to my parents all the time
and I hold it over their head it's kind
of nice to be like I'm making enough
money Mountain now that I feel like I
have I'm buying my possession how this
sounds so bad but what the fact that I
can help my parents out if they're in a
financial situation right now feels so
good to me yeah and not because like
they're gonna be happy and secure but
like I told you yes well yes that's I
feel that today I told you so I totally
I'm the oh you wanted me to be a teacher
teacher is that what you that was your
big site for me mom was to be an English
professor well guess who wouldn't be
going out today not that my mom is it
demands these things from me and wants
me to buy her stuff my mom would be
happy shopping and eating at Goodwill
the rest of her life yes I said eating
but I do feel I feel great being able to
like to being rich yes and I being able
to like buy things from the people I
love
so that they can so I can buy their love
yeah I mean I I yes well I did a book
tour for the first book and we weren't
going to South Florida where my parents
are so I flew them to the Boston and New
York uh events and put them up in a
hotel yeah and they when they got there
they were like it's so nice that your
publisher did this and I was like I did
this I did this and they were like oh my
god you did this and I was like yes yes
I did yeah and they were like
that I mean I think they are not
slightly uncomfortable but they kind of
I think they've lost the power yeah so
then I like when I went home for
Thanksgiving I was like I'm staying in
an air B&B
and they were like wait what and I was
like I will be by the beach if you need
me
but I'm not staying in the house and
they were upset I think that is such
that is what my therapist taught me is
one of the greatest boundaries you can
have is not staying at home with your
parents
yes when you go home it's such a power
move and it's there and it protects
you from so much they're gonna take
offense to it but in the end it really
pretty night and I don't do it I stay at
home with my parents
and I do the opposite of like yeah my
room's trashed but guess what I I pay
for everything when I'm home yeah I eat
out constantly you eat out more in one
week than you do a whole year when I'm
home so I'm my room's gonna be a mess
and you're not gonna say anything about
it to me mom it's like you're buying
freedom it's freedom you're buying
freedom and it's complete freedom and I
and I always question like if I if I was
because I have been broke and relied on
them and it wasn't good for our
relationship nothing else is even good
for our relationship either me feeling
like I have some kind of upper hand
because I'm paying for things because
they're not even asking for it but it
just I don't know what my point is my
point is I mean I think I would have
they're a lot my parents and I think I
would have been very I think it would
have damaged our relationship further
for me to stay in the house and so and
then they were upset and I they have no
boundaries and them and my sister have
no boundaries it's like very weird what
they talk about and and are and I kind
of have pulled back and then the family
narrative is Gabby's a bitch but so I'm
like but I was like this is the craziest
as I said they were upset that I was
staying at the air B&B and I said well
that's fine like I you know I'm gonna be
in your city in an air B&B if you want
to see me I'm so happy to spend every
second with you if you don't want to see
me I'll have a vacation they lost it and
then I was like this is like this is the
healthiest boundary one and two I
realized that they want to see you more
than you want to see that yes so you
have the power it's really good that you
did that and not a lot of people do that
and if you're listening at home and you
just got done with the holidays and
you're like I could never do that yes
you could yeah not you don't have to go
home and stay with your family when you
are going home for the holidays you can
you have money
yes yes of course you but you could even
say with a friend
ya don't have to go back home there's
nothing there's no contract that we all
just we all just blindly go yeah we I'm
gonna stay in my old childhood bedroom
none of that has to happen and yes they
will be disappointed and they'll be like
what does this mean
and use my line say I'm I'll be in this
in in the your same city I'm happy to
spend as much time with you as you'd
like
if you're that upset with me and you
don't want to see me I understand and
I'll hang out my friends it's a good
line I don't know how to do I mean it's
it I did it one time I went back and got
a hotel and and I never did it again
because I'm always like I just want to
save the money and stay at home but I
think you're right in the end it's just
better to have it's so guilty that's why
you look at what's worth it to you yeah
and then if having you know like to
Dropbox accounts which I did and I was
like why don't I just use Google Drive
okay I and you get rid of them and then
then that's the equivalent that's like
okay that's like a $9.99 payment a month
yeah I don't have a I will never have
expensive handbags cuz most of them are
made of leather and I don't believe in
leather goods but also because I've
never cared about leather I've never
cared about handbags I'm just I never
and I quit and I want to I want to be a
girl who cares about nice things but my
bag is always a disgusting tote in a
gift bag that's why a lot of money
advice is to generalize do you want to
look at what matters to you okay
and what matters to each person is
different so the the caught the coffee a
day thing like don't don't have shame
about the things that actually really
matter to you that you're spending money
on and just yeah a lot of the shaming
stuff is specifically towards women
they'll be like don't get a manicure
don't get your hair dyed and it's like
oh I'm sorry you're gonna tell dudes not
to buy sneakers like do you know what I
mean it's all directed at women I want
to not get my hair done or never again
I'm so tired of it and I resent if they
don't have to do it Gaby they don't have
to do it it's that picture of Beyonce
very dressed up and edge here and
wearing jeans never loved anything
[Music]